je remercie d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors à ce jour seuls 11 5%
des 5 8 millions de danois ont été
vaccinées ce qui n'est pas un peu trop
tôt selon vous pour des cons finis
rouvrir les salles de spectacle les
salles de sport etc
non pas du tout parce que comme vous
l'avez dit dans votre introduction et on
pourra voir le passé sanitaires et c'est
pas seulement et la vaccination qui est
qui qui le rend possible et on peut
aussi s est resté négatif ou committee
stuff et dans ce cas le pasteur est
valable pour 72 heures et il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de possibilités de se
faire le tester ou de marque
donc si on avis si on en italie et voix
sont par exemple c'est peut-être
possible qu'ils aient moi je pense et vu
la faible et continuer comme ça
limitation ou la marque etc c'est bien
l'heure de commencer la réouverture
parce que tout le monde en a envie et
c'est vraiment comme quand vous imagine
contre les gens sont très heureux de
pouvoir s'asseoir à nouveau sur les crs
et de ses trains et non je ne crains pas
une hausse des compagnies de
contamination parce que je pense qu'on
connaît avec hassen faire les choses
bien en main
alors à partir du 21 mai le plan prévoit
de relever la jauge des événements en
extérieur à 2000 personnes le retour des
étudiants en présentiel à 50% pour
l'euro de football 1 dont quatre matches
doivent se jouer à copenhague
le plan prévoit la présence d'environ
seize mille spectateurs est ce qu'on
peut craindre une troisième vague dans
ce contexte là bien sûr c'est possible
mais je ne le pense pas et si on
respecte les règles de distanciation et
les v et de porter le masque et si tout
le monde va le passeport sanitaires
je pense que cela va se passer et
ah si bien mais il faut dire que le clan
sur des moments la situation qui peut
changer et si et si le niveau de
contamination est dense et il se peut
que l'on puisse le nombre de spectateurs
qui peuvent regarder les matchs de foot
par exemple et il y à une surveillance
de très près de la situation tout le
temps là par les autorités et du
gouvernement
alors vous l'avez dire pour aller au
cinéma au théâtre au restaurant dans les
centres de fitness il faudra vous
présenter un passeport sanitaire
certifiant d'un test négatif de -2 72
heures d'une vaccination ou alors d'une
guérison à récente du kobe de 19 alors
beaucoup justement dénonce une atteinte
à leur liberté
estime qu'il s'agit là de discrimination
qu'ils se sentent obligés de se faire
vacciner
que pensez vous de ces propos là alors
je ne dirais pas beaucoup parce que
selon un récent sondage près de 60% des
danois sont favorables ou pas sanitaires
et c'est vrai qu'il ya eu de
l'opposition et de la part des médias
grecs
comme vous l'avait dit et dans la
sélection mais c'est une très faible
minorité de la population et il y a eu
aussi un est un peu de cette opposition
de la part et par cinq professeurs qui
sont petits sont à demander à leurs
sillons de voir le pas salutaire de
crème de détériorer les relations avec
les clients
aussi et dans les liait salle des sports
en ont craint que d'être li lé personne
aille pas se faire tester assez souvent
et c'est ce qui s'est tramé sais pas
c'est pas beaucoup et la plupart lésions
sens très très heureux et pourrait
reprendre un peu la vie normale
on avait beaucoup bu et on fait beaucoup
pour peu tout le monde à un accès et à
se passe à 10 heures ou demain et tout
le monde ait accès à siphonner senti pas
un portail et numériques sécurisés et
c'est resté là et de tataouine et un sac
terre ou bien par table alors sonne le
danemark abandonné à les vaccins
d'astrazeneca et de johnson & johnson
vous pensez qu'il y aura suffisamment de
doses pour vacciner les les danois qui
le souhaiteront oui avec les vaccins de
facet biotech et l'irak sans du
gouvernement je pense que toute la
population à tulle 2 sera
vacciner cet été un dernier mot
rapidement selig a rapidement peut-être
est-ce que vous diriez que les autorités
danoises ont bien géré cette pandémie
oui absolument et je pense que la
plupart de la population de l'état nous
rase ans tenait même et parce qu'on est
resté conscient du temps j ai de la
maladie on a vécu regard et l'inde ou le
brésil pour voir comment cela se passe
si on ne maîtrise pas bien et le queen
kiss neuf donc oui je pense qu'on a bien
fait et joe johnson merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur de médecine à
l'université de copenhague merci
beaucoup